come up accept your little award thank
your agent and your God and on behalf of
Amy I'd like to um thank the devil and
all the dark
Lords thank you to uh Satan for giving
me inspiration on how to play this
role a lot of people come up here and
they thank Jesus for this award I want
you to know that no one had less to do
with this award than Jesus
he didn't help me a bit if it was up to
him Caesar Milan would be up here with
that damn
dog so all I can say and suck at Jesus
this award is my God now good evening
Godless
sodomites by giving you a golden idol to
worship kneel before your God
Babylon so we've been talking about the
gold Globes this week and uh one of the
films that came up was Gladiator 2 and
there's a little controversy with
Denzel uh supposedly a scene that was
cut was he kissed a dude it was cut they
cut it out they cut it oh and oh so it
never made it to no never made it to the
cut of the film and he was asked about
it and he was like don't make a big deal
about it you know I pecked guy on the
hand pecked him on the on the lips and
then I killed him so he was like it's
not really a thing wow wow I don't know
why they throw stuff like that that in
there you know what I mean and then they
cut out so the point he was like you
know he was like don't make a big deal
but then you know the LGBT community was
a little bit upset because they're like
well we're not getting full
representation in the film and from
ancient Rome very historically accurate
um so I was like gotcha okay but anyway
um I want to talk a little bit about
Hollywood and their attitude towards God
we're going to circle back around to
Denzel because there's some recent
develop in developments in his life that
are very
interesting but we're going to start out
by watching this clip from Nikki Glazer
she hosted the Golden Globes she said
something that was kind of interesting
I've seen it you've seen it okay here we
go welcome back if you're just joining
us now why why now what took you so long
anyway it's time for our mid show recap
and I'm here on the floor with all of my
peers Just go with it and this is so
exciting cuz everywhere you look there's
a Fanning L Dakota
Payton the air is thick with the smell
of signature fragrances and the
lingering stench of Ballroom salmon
Ballroom salmon is actually the name of
Stanley tui's new cologne now available
at bu Deo
so so much has already happened in the
first half and the acceptance speeches
have been on fire who got shouted out
the most let's look at the numbers all
right cast and crew are leading the way
with 11 mentions moms are holding strong
with three
shoutouts God creator of the universe
zero
mentions and Mario Lopez host of Access
Hollywood
won all
right no surprise in this Godless Town
that's sad that they would say something
like that even in a Gest and and people
laugh at it it was the ones that got the
most laughs as well was and do you know
there's a video that circulates on the
internet of uh keeping track of
different people in the number of
mentions like at the Oscars or different
Awards and they they have a list of like
guess who's number one at least in that
video I don't know how no is Harvey
Weinstein and then they get down the
list and like later on is like God is
like at the end with the you know less
amount of mentions than all the the
Oscar you're saying I forget if it was
Oscars or Emy or Golden Globe or
whatever I mean she is speaking truth
that it is a Godless Town it absolutely
is but I I just think it's so
interesting that you know Jesus was
offered the whole world and he's like no
not taking it and then these people are
offered the same thing and they take it
you see where it takes them and they
think that they're on top of the world
they have all of the fame they have all
of the money like people literally
worship them and they think that they
can just you know trample on God and
Christianity but it's sad to think that
you know if they continue down this road
God loves them so much and he's like
pleading and and trying to reach them
and and save their soul but eventually
the road to that leads to destruction
and S Satan whom they follow is just
sitting there laughing at the situation
and is like yeah keep doing this because
I know what your end result will be and
godess I I you God is weeping over them
literally weeping wanting to save them
but they spit him in his face yeah and
it's not the first time this has
happened she's kind of playing off some
other things that have been said
throughout the
years a lot of people come up here and
they thank Jesus for this award I want
you to know that no one had less to do
with this award than
Jesus he didn't help me a bit if it was
up to him Caesar Milan be up here with
that damn dog
so all I can say is suck at Jesus this
award is my God now wow dude I mean she
didn't have to go that far no yeah no
that's wow but pretty Blasphemous right
yeah and then there was this Steven coar
from the emys you might have seen this
one as well thank
you it's uh thank you very much it's uh
it's a pleasure to be here tonight good
evening Godless
[Applause]
sodomites what what are you doing I'm
bringing the truth
John we're in Hollywood the belly of the
Beast you can't just you can't just read
the prompter I'm reading the prompter in
here you can read that
paum a word show banter is not paum
reality television celebrates The Human
[Applause]
Condition by Illuminating what's
extraordinary in the ordinary
person it warps the minds of our
children and weakens the resolve of our
allies
[Applause]
the results are often dramatic and
always
unexpected we're here to honor
achievement in that category by giving
you a golden idol to worship kneel
before your God
Babylon guys didn't you make a video
Once that's like one of our most watched
videos about the Oscars and how it looks
exactly like Babylon and have like a
Babylonian statue outside of it or
something yeah I think there's truth in
every joke right so you know as he's
throwing this out there there's an
element of Truth like there there are
actual people that believe that that
it's Babylon and Babylon was just known
for you know spiritual confusion mixture
of everything like you can do whatever
you want there's no rules what's the uh
theater um where they award Kodak yeah
and they have like the Ishtar gate there
yeah so if you actually go to um just
Google like where the Oscars held and
you look at the building the codec the
um it's it's at a mall that's on
Hollywood Boulevard and when you see
that um you'll see the elephants and the
design that's in there they have the
Gate of Ishtar they have all the
Babylonian Gods and there's a plaque
right there in the U in the ground level
that says this is the Babylonian court
and so you know even though he's making
a joke yes there is actual like they
made that they made that Recreation of
that mall after a 1912 movie called
intolerance and so um you know it it was
a remodel of Babylon and you look at the
movie and you look at that it's the same
thing wow you know I wonder I I don't
want to go like too far like conspiracy
theory or anything like that or
Christian conspiracy but I find it
interesting that a week after the Golden
Globes La is on fire right
now right I mean God God is merciful but
sometimes you know things happen hitting
the celebrities homes so I don't know
that's my two cents we don't know
yeah James Wood lost his
home um so we talked a little bit about
Denzel Washington in the beginning and
it was uh late
December uh around the 20th or so or so
that Denzel Washington actually got
baptized did you know that I know he's
been outspoken Christian for a while
because he's mentioned it in in
interviews and things in the past yeah
right he just turned 70 years old he got
baptized and uh there's a clip can watch
on the internet it's about 18 minutes
long of the whole thing I watched it and
he uh also at the same time received a
Minister's license to train to be an
ordained
minister and you know he was up for this
award and and I just I just want to read
a quote from People magazine uh that
they just commented on in uh November
just prior to his baptism of some things
that he said
he said things I said about God when I
was a little boy just reciting them in
church along with everybody else I know
now God is love God is the only way God
is the true way God blesses it's my job
to lift God up to give him praise to
make sure that anyone and everyone I
speak to the rest of my life understands
that he is responsible for me Washington
wrote in his essay when you see me you
see the best I could do with what I've
been given by my Lord Lord and Savior
I'm unafraid I don't care what anyone
thinks see talking about the fear part
of it you can't talk like that and win
Oscars you can't talk like that and
party you can't say that in this town
referring to
Hollywood I'm free now it's not talked
about in this town it's not talked about
it's not talked about it's not
fashionable it's not sexy but that
doesn't mean people in Hollywood don't
believe there a really interesting
statement in light of all the things
that have happened in his life and you
see what appears to be this dramatic
turnaround now and you know in some ways
you might think well it's kind of sad
like he's a little late to the party
because in his baptism he talks about
his mom used to tell him about all these
things and he was raised with
Christianity I mean you can you can tell
in different clips that you watch him
different interviews and and things he's
he's familiar with the Bible you know
he's he's been able to quote um portions
of it
but you know we're we're looking at this
and and one wonders like is this real
there are different celebrities that
that appear to come to Christ M you know
like Kanye remember Kanye uh there was
all this stuff about Kanye and we we did
some shows so you know if you're um uh
watching maybe recently or for the first
time go way back in LED live some of our
first shows we did was about Kanye
and now you know as of 2024 Rolling
Stone did a report where he's announcing
Yeezy porn amid reports of adult film
company and you know it's easy I think
to say something and and maybe he did
pick a right direction but he doesn't
appear to be going that same way now and
so what's the point time will tell right
we don't know whether Denzel's
conversion is genuine or
not um
time will tell I I think something that
we as Christians need to be aware of is
that there are Christians celebrities
out there who you know again seem like
they really are trying to go down this
road and and again like they might not
be living a perfect life according to
what we say they should be living but
they might be living according to the
light that they have I mean they're
living in a very dark place Hollywood
and the music industry is dark and they
might have this little light and they
say okay I'm responding to that and we
can't be the judge of that but um it
could also be that there's people in
there who are saying they're Christian
who are like you're saying not really
Christian who are not showing the fruit
um I'm thinking of of Beyonce I think
even if you have very little light as a
Christian you probably know that you're
not supposed to dress up as baffet if
you Proclaim that you believe in God
right and
so I think as us as Christians we need
to be cautious to rubber stamp someone
because they say well I'm a Christian
now and say okay well they're clean to
watch or they're clean to listen to
that's what we need to be extremely
cautious with yeah Lady Gaga prays with
her crew before they do a concert and
then she you know would make a a video
music video about her riding on the back
and choosing Judas over Jesus like that
doesn't add up you know so you
definitely buy your fruits and you know
man still pray for these people like AB
you know there's a lot of people Paul I
mean he was out dragging Christians out
in the street and killing them right in
front of him and God flipped him um
Nebuchadnezzar he's the king of the most
Babylonian Society the originator right
the king God flipped for good so you
know that there there's a possibility
that God can win these Hearts but you
know you just pray that that because of
their influence that they actually will
fully surrender to God mhm yeah and
Denzel's coming towards what he claims
to be the end of his career if you read
the interviews you know he's really not
going to make that many movies in front
of the camera wants to work more behind
but I hope what that does is he
chooses things that are uplifting you
know things that'll change people's
lives make a make a difference you've
both alluded to this this idea of fruit
in one's life in Matthew 7:1 15-20 it
says beware of false prophets who who
come to you in sheep's clothing but
inwardly they are ravenous wolves you
will know them by their fruits do men
gather grapes from Thorn bushes or figs
from thistles even so every good tree
Bears good fruit but a bad tree Bears
Bad fruit a good tree cannot bear bad
fruit nor can a bad tree bear good fruit
every tree that does not bear good fruit
is cut down and thrown into the fire
therefore by their fruits you will know
them mhm
so we hope and pray that Denzel is truly
converted but we don't know yet time
will tell time will tell the Bible says
though as a guiding principle whenever
somebody
does um enter that space of taking
Christianity Christianity is it's not a
label it's a lifestyle right and so if
that's your life the Bible advises us to
abstain from every form of evil and so
hopefully that's what he'll do like no
more equalizer movies right yeah um
things of that nature because that
wouldn't be consistent with one's
profession mhm so and I think something
we as Christians can take away from it
too is that and I like this approach
because we're trying to be balanced you
know understanding God judges the heart
that's right and I think what we as
Christians could take away from this is
some Christians can be the absolute
worst cruel mean people when the
celebrity comes to Christ they will just
C and then it's
like you know we have to be careful with
that because that's not showing fruit if
you look at someone and they just came
from the darkest place and they say
they're Christian now who are you the
judge like unless I guess like you said
we see the fruit right that's biblical
but we we can't just cut them to the
ground and it's
like how how do you know that
you're going to be on the right side
when Heaven comes and they're not might
be flipped upside down because who knows
maybe they are showing fruit that you're
not seeing you can't you're not in their
home you're not on their heart you know
anything and and then you're outside
because you're actually treating people
terribly but again I agree with you it
is about the fruit so if people like
this will continue making like like like
Kanye West like Yeezy porn or Beyonce
like baffet I think that is showing the
fruit of not a real conversion um but
I'm just saying we need to be very
cautious with telling people oh you're
just fake no yeah the Bible says let
your light so shine before men that they
that they may see your good works and
glorify the God in heaven so it's like
you know the things that you do and I
know this is a weird space the whole
acting world because they believe it's
pretend but you need to pretend
just like it's real you know what I mean
like I don't believe that you should
divorce your actions I love those actors
I think it was Kurt Cameron that
wouldn't even kiss another girl yeah it
it had to be his wife or whatever he
wasn't going to do that scene and and I
mean that's that's totally respectable I
wish there was more people that would
step up and do that kind of a thing age
if you're calling yourself a Christian
and you're going to make films I hope
and pray that you're going to make films
that glorify God so that people when
they see those good works M they see oh
there's something different about this
individual the Bible says in Psalm 34:14
that we should turn from Evil and choose
the good and you know you know we can't
say all we can do here is speculate
because we can't read people's hearts
but you know occasionally somebody comes
along and and you really wonder like Kat
Von D right she has what appears to be
this conversion experience what I find
very interesting is you haven't heard
anything about her since mhm well the
people with the microphone don't really
care to highlight God no they don't but
it makes but but you also wonder like is
she now living just this very quiet life
out of the
Limelight you know living out of
Christianity um growing in Christ you
wonder I mean we don't know we don't
know we hope so we don't know one of the
people we used to work with Mikey just
reached out to us and sent us a video of
a young lady Taylor uh Alicia who
mentioned our ministry in one of her
videos and probably has more views than
we'll get on this video ever but it made
an impact in her life and she was on
patreon making we'll say immodest
content uh sometimes she says only fans
but I don't think she was ever on only
fans and it made a difference in her
life now she has a clothing line you
know I've just looked at her website
where it's very modest you know
promoting modesty promote modesty send
people bibes you know that kind of thing
and again don't know the heart but it it
it appears like she's making positive
changes and going in the right direction
and we pray and hope that continues so
kudos to to Taylor yeah when you call
yourself a Christian act like it yeah
and it seems like she absolutely is you
know I was I I actually told my husband
last night about this shout out that we
got from her video and I was like I was
telling him like she came up in my feet
once I had no clue this was her past
because she looked like such a
conservative modest Christian female and
I'm like what that was your pass and I
said that's the power of God that's the
power of God that can change hearts and
he wants to do it to all of these people
so I'm praying that this that Denzel's
you know conversion is real that Justin
Bieber's conversion is real you know
that God can take hold of their hearts
and that he can you know we might see
them in heaven and they might not know
everything yet and they might learn a
lot just like I don't know everything
yet but the God's like you know whatever
light you have if you obey that if you
move forward in that light he he loves
you and he's like I'm I'm going to say
save you yeah and more than that he
wants to do it for every one of us not
just all these celebrities God wants to
change every single one of our lives and
bring us to a place where we are like
him in character that's what it's all
about yeah we we need to understand as
Christians that we we don't change the
world when we talk about Christ we
change the world when we talk like
Christ yeah and that's the difference
that's that's that's probably the fruits
right there yeah you can still talk
about Christ like the Nikki glacer uh
lady in the beginning she she mentioned
God but was it you know right was it in
the positive light when you talk like
Jesus right that's when you can actually
see the fruits and and even more so when
you don't even have to say a word but
your actions speak of Jesus MH all right
well we hope that you enjoyed this video
as part of our little Golden Globe
series we've been doing this week make
sure you like this video give it a
thumbs up share it with somebody who
needs to see it and we'd like to hear
your comments so put those below we read
those sometimes we can respond to those
we take those things into consideration
and um also if you want to help support
us go to
ll. or you can go to lightwear get some
of our merch it looks like everybody's
wearing something today which is pretty
cool you can't get all these Felipe's
got a donor exclusive shirt and Scotty's
got a event exclusive shirt yep you had
to be there sorry that was in August of
2024 you can get these two yeah but
these two you can get on lightwear shop
so uh thanks for joining us and making
us part of your day and we hope to see
you next time this has been LED live
[Music]